another heated school board meeting on
the agenda tonight is a political battle
within the school district is now coming
to a head trustees are set to make two
crucial votes with the superintendent
and the board president's jobs both on
the line tonight sasha loftis joining us
now live near flamingo and eastern where
that meeting is just now getting started
sasha
denise that meeting just kicked off and
up until a few minutes ago there was a
line of people outside waiting to get in
to attend that meeting now this as that
contentious battle within the school
board could come to a head tonight with
those two crucial votes
the big talker tonight is the future of
superintendent dr jesus jarrah's job
trustees will discuss the possible
termination of his contract that was
brought up by three board members linda
cavazos's job as board president also on
the line as trustees will vote on
whether to strip her of that title
cavazos held a press conference
yesterday to address allegations against
her what i'm hoping to accomplish
is that somewhere our colleagues can
come together
and we can figure out that path forward
because as i said at the end of my
remarks our kids are depending on us
three separate trustees are pushing to
oust cavazos as president including
trustee williams who claimed president
cavazos bullied other board members
president cavazos denied those
allegations
now to pass each of these items four out
of the seven trustees would need to vote
yes now heated or public comment rather
tonight is expected to be heated as it
has been over the last few months at
these board meetings we'll be here all
night so stay with eight news now for
the latest on air and online reporting
live sasha loftis live local now